these are a subclass of ciliates called
hypotricks they usually have a big mouth
and a flat body some even have
interesting pigments like the gold
dotting this frantically spiraling
individual or this pink tinted one now
we're not sure what those pigments are
but things like a flat body or big mouth
or pigments are not enough what really
sets hypotricks apart from other
ciliates is their thick hair hypotricks
take these individual cilia and bundle
them together into something bigger
called a sear eye like a rope made of
smaller strands and it's thanks to these
Serie that hypertricks do something
unusual for single-celled organisms they
walk